does Canada have the cure for the
hangover we've created a facility to
test the words greatest hangover cures
and we're testing them all I'm dr.
Keller wertham doctor of internal
medicine I'm Frank Krantz I'm not a
doctor but I've been hung over a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover lab Jeff
Miller hey how's it going and what do
you do I'm the editor of the Los Angeles
edition of Thrillist
with last night a lot of fun it was it
was the next level of a fancy drink we
can we spy on you can we just yeah let's
pull up footage from last night
oh wow I went to a whiskey tasting to
start the night it was ten different rye
whiskeys
whiskey is up on the top of the list of
alcohols that will make you feel shitty
than it really so some of the whiskey's
last night we're like 140 proof normal
whiskey's about 80 so you're talking
real intense now we're at a bar a minute
with a friend but it was like glasses of
whiskey and shots of Jameson oh wow man
you did it how do you feel I have a
headache I feel like there's no more
water in my system whatsoever
oh we did some vital signs we check your
blood pressures we check your blood
sugar and then we tried a game to test
your motor skills your depth perception
and that went pretty poorly yes yeah
zero pretend yes I hope you're gonna
like this cure I hope it's something
that hits home
I hope so too I mean he went strong last
night 17 20 whiskeys yeah
he's got the classic hangover symptoms
dehydration headaches stomach grumbling
and just feeling very fatigued poutine
is the ultimate french-canadian comfort
food french fries cheese curds and gravy
that's what he's getting and he's
getting a hot steaming plate of it when
you have a lot of alcohol it destroys
your body's ability to do some other
metabolic functions and that leads to
this hormonal surge and this specific
hormone called Galan in that makes you
crave really fatty greasy foods they're
gonna release a whole bunch of dopamine
and they're gonna give you what your
body's craving at that moment I just
want to tell you guys I can see what's
here this is one of the most exciting
moments of my life you guys talk amongst
yourselves I'm going for it
amazing I think that hugs are in order
really I think that's where that's where
we're at
I'm so much happier five minutes and
should we go back to some vitals and see
how we do all right
125 over 80 so the big salty meal
dropped your blood pressure so blood
sugar 116 your body might be liking that
higher glucose level sure and now we
just got to do the motor slows down
let's do it sweet round 2 I'm excited
let's do it what do you think feeling
much better so the deal is you know this
this game of horseshoes is testing your
motor skills your depth perception your
focus you have the poutine cure we're
gonna see if your score gets better you
certainly feel better we'll see the
translates to a better game I think it's
gonna happen let's do it
here come on in
all right come back Wow there's actually
something that happens in your body when
you're metabolizing alcohol that ruins
the way other things are broken down in
the body so your liver has to deal with
the alcohol it's a toxin so it can't
make sugar the way it's supposed to
it can't process fats the way it's
supposed to and this all leads to like a
whole bunch of imbalance in certain
hormone levels and one of them this one
one called gallon in is is increased and
it makes you crave fatty foods like
crazy
you also need sugar because your blood
sugars have kind of gone down like yours
had and so you you want something that's
gonna be really calorically dense which
fats have the most calories per gram of
any other food that doesn't necessarily
mean that it cures a hangover in the
sense of that it's like fixing the
problems that you have but that rush of
greasy fatty foods tells your brain that
is what I needed I feel a hundred times
better I think that the poutine actually
cured the hangover I think the water
helped cure the hangover
I think getting a little physical
activity if it's just with the arm
helped helped with the hangover and now
who wants to go drink some whiskey
tonight I would I have not seen us have
that much success at least in the way
someone's feeling since we started this
yeah it invigorated him from the very
first bite he was glowing we redid his
vitals miraculously the the salty fatty
poutine brought his blood pressure down
I think it has to be number one of the
unhealthy cures right I I'm gonna give
it da - because it's not healthy poutine
worked for his hangover at this
particular moment if I'm just evaluating
is this a good hangover cure
then I yeah I have to give it a B+ I'm
dr. Keller wertham I'm Fran Kranz thanks
for visiting the GQ hangover lab
for more tips and hangover cures
subscribe to the channel and for
delicious recipes on poutine go google
it